joe swinson you have changed
the liberal democrat position on brexit
from a people's vote
to revoking do you worry that
overturning the result of that 2016
referendum will to quote norman lamb
leave half the country
angry and the social contract in this
country broken
to be clear our policy is still that a
people's vote
is the best way to get out of this
brexit impasse that we should put a
specific brexit proposal to the people
to have the final say and we've argued
for that for three and a half years
and we will continue to argue for that
but in the circumstances
which can arise where we find ourselves
in a general election
that might be the last chance for the
public to have their say
on brexit as a party that strongly
believes
in our place in the european union that
that is our best
future that we should stop brexit we
have to give
the people that clear choice and say
that a liberal democrat majority
government would stop brexit
by revoking article 50. and are you
using that position because
deep down you don't think you'll ever
have to get to the point where you will
try
to revoke article 50 or would you
genuinely like to do that if you want a
general election
i would love to do that but i think
brexit is
catastrophic for our country now and for
generations to come
i think our place in the european union
is
where we have influence it's how we
secure our prosperity and trade with
countries where we don't feel we have to
compromise our values to
reach those accommodations and deals
it's how we tackle the big challenges
that we face whether that's
international terrorism or the climate
emergency we need to work with other
countries
to do that so i want to keep us in the
eu
and i want to build a liberal society
that is open
fair and inclusive so absolutely i want
to win a majority and be
prime minister there is a legitimacy
question in all of this let's just say
that the liberal democrats won a
majority at the next election let's just
put that out there as an idea in 2015
david cameron won
a general election he won 37
of the popular vote he won 11 million
votes
from the public and that gave him you
could argue a mandate
if you won you would be prepared to win
on that level of votes perhaps
but over the turn 17.4 million votes
in a referendum it's anti-democratic joe
swinson well
i think if we win a majority in
parliament and ignore the 17.4 million
if we win a majority in parliament on
the very
clear position of stopping brexit
then that will be a mandate to do that
now
i want to change our voting system beth
you know that i think that we should
have a different voting system but let's
just go back this is the system that we
have
and incidentally it's a system that does
not make it easy
for third parties to break through and
so if we are able to
achieve that which i do believe is
possible because
of the strength of feeling on these
issues in the country
if we do that then i think people will
expect us
to fulfill what we've said we would do
in that election campaign
but do you accept the 17.4 million
people
who voted to leave the eu in 2016
that you coming in and saying i'm now
going to overturn the result of that
referendum
that is anti-democratic there's no other
way of cutting it
i i i fundamentally disagree
democracy did not end on the 23rd of
june 2016. i've spoken to plenty of
people
who have changed their mind since that
time there are plenty of people
who did not have a say in that
referendum and who
are now able to vote who are in our
society
who are adults and part of our community
so
you know it's not as if that is set in
an aspect forever there are also 17.4
million people that did have their say
that voted to leave
over three years later we still haven't
left and now you are saying actually i'm
going to revoke
i'm not going to do it at all i mean and
then you say you're a liberal democrat
you're a democrat that scientific
democrats
no it's about giving people the choice
i'm standing up for my position
for my party's position of what we
believe in
what we think is the best future for the
country and then letting
the public choose and i'll happily have
a discussion about how we change our
voting system
to make it fairer that is another
passion of mine because i think we need
to reform our politics in a whole
host of ways our country needs
significant change and reform
more broadly and the first step has to
be
protecting our place in the european
union because that is how we can protect
jobs
how we can protect our public services
and how we can protect our international
influence and security but jason going
back to what norman
lam said about being people being angry
this is actually the politics of
division isn't it you are like
an iteration of nigel farage on the
other end of the spectrum
he is the brexit party and you are
turning the liberal democrats into the
non-brexit stop
brexit party you are as extreme as him
just on the other side of the debate and
i think that could turn a lot of
voters off well i fundamentally disagree
i fundamentally disagree we are clear
on our position on european union
membership
but i respect the views of people who
take a different view i recognize they
hold those in genuine good faith
and perhaps most importantly i believe
that every single person
in our country is valuable and should be
respected
and have equality and nigel farage is
prepared to stand in front of a breaking
point poster
that is designed to stoke fear and
hatred and division in our communities
and what we are proposing in terms of an
inclusive fair and liberal society is
fundamentally you're proposing to
overturn the result of a popular vote
because you didn't like how it went
that's what we are proposing to give
people the choice
ideally in a people's vote on a specific
brexit deal
which we have argued for and if that is
not possible
to give people the choice in a general
election i would like to leave and have
a referendum
on a deal with an actual vote i would
prefer
to have a referendum on a specific
brexit deal
that gives people the chance to choose
this is what brexit looks like
do you want to go ahead with that or do
you prefer so why do we have
why revoking manifesto policy because it
may be that this general election
after three and a half years of brexit
impasse
is the last chance that people have and
the logical extension of the point that
you're putting to me
is that there should be no option for
people in such a general election
to be able to choose to stop brexit and
i i disagree
i mean if a democracy cannot change its
mind it ceases to be a democracy and
it's not me that said that first it was
david davis the leading brexiteer
you you're happy that the 2014 scottish
referendum vote stands because what you
liked it
and scotland voted to remain part of the
united kingdom
but you're not happy that the 2016
brexit referendum vote stands
because it didn't go the liberal
democrats way that seems really
undemocratic to me
it's actually a very consistent position
that we think that we are better working
with other countries
we are better working with our closest
neighbors to solve our shared problems
and it is the same argument for scotland
being part of the uk
family of nations as for the uk working
within the european union
where we can better address the
challenges that we face
and what we have right now is a
situation of chaos
we have jobs being lost we have
uncertainty
we need a way out of that i think the
best way out is a people's vote
but in a general election then i will
argue that we should stop brexit
altogether
okay just couple more things jason just
in terms of a general election
it could be that the liberal democrats
are the power broker
after a general election does
revoking article 50 become a red line
for you in a supply and confidence deal
i mean
what should voters expect that you would
make conditions
uh for perhaps propping up another prime
minister
well i don't think we should second
guess the electorate this is a decision
that they get to make about how they
choose to vote
and there is no reason to assume
that there has to be a scenario
where either boris johnson or jeremy
corbyn
has to be prime minister neither of
those men is fit
to be prime minister and i will not vote
to make either of those men prime
minister but you can understand why
people would be nervous because
and this is old ground i know people
have asked you about this day but of
course back in
2010 there was the issue about tuition
fees and you said
that you wouldn't charge tuition fees
and then in coalition government the
liberal democrats reversed that decision
and then there was a big breakdown of
trust between your voters
and all of you as politicians so just to
be clear
is revocation a red line i mean is that
what you would be in terms of of
government
i'll be very clear about our policy we
are saying that if there is a liberal
democrat majority government
we will revoke article 50. we're a party
that wants to stop brexit
and we will work with other people as we
have been in the people's vote campaign
we have been working with all sorts of
different parties and individuals
to pursue that aim and if we do not
secure a majority lib dem government
we will still be working to stop brexit
for example through the mechanism of a
people's vote
of course we will continue to do that
but boris johnson and jeremy corbyn
are not fit to be prime minister and our
country deserves
an alternative credible choice that is
the liberal democrats under my
leadership
and just finally j swinson sam guimar
joined you
uh this weekend have you had more
conversations with other
mps that are feeling politically
homeless in westminster since saturday
well yes i'm having conversations with
other members of parliament
you know in labor and the conservatives
there's a lot of unhappy
mps who feel that their parties have
deserted them
people are looking at the lib dem
conference where sam and
chukka and luciana are receiving such a
warm welcome
they say they feel at home that it is
the right decision
and i think there's other mps that are
are looking at that with a great deal of
interest he's going to be pulling
someone else
out of your hat this week many of these
things take time but i'm certainly
optimistic that the liberal democrats
will continue to grow
great thank you very much thank you